the jurogan experience
again i keep going back to that one
point which is it doesn't really matter
what the facts are anymore it does it
as an example today was now i'm kind of
bouncing around a little bit but today
was uh hearings up on the hill uh the
senate armed services committee was
holding hearings so who did they have
they had secretary of defense lloyd
austin they had uh
centcom commander general mckenzie great
guy they had
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff uh general milley
so
they all
to
the last one said yes uh we were
advising the president
that um
you know our advice is to maintain a
small troop presence a minimum of 2 500
troops right
in afghanistan
um and our belief was not that it would
collapse as quickly as it did but that
it would collapse if you took those
advisors those troops out that it would
collapse maybe by fall this fall
and
yet you've got the president
saying
i don't recall being told any of that
and that's okay now because
no and nobody's questioning it right
nobody's saying saying well hold on no
how about some pushback how about saying
what do you mean you don't recall this
is one of the most important decisions
you've made or will be making and you
don't recall whether your senior top
military advisors were telling you that
in their
advice keep the troops in there
for a period of time
and he's saying i don't remember and
there's really no serious pushback this
whole hearing if anybody wants to know
what washington dc is like and how that
city runs i'd recommend maybe on
thursday watching some more of these
hearings
on the afghanistan process because
it's just
on one hand it's very depressing it's
just a [ __ ] show you've got the senators
on the armed services committee who have
been there who have been privy to all
sorts of intelligence over the past few
years right
now sitting in a hearing to understand
what happened what went wrong with the
afghan withdrawal and they're all acting
as if you know
they could be surprised by this
when when these
politicians have been sitting up for
capitol hill
being briefed on this [ __ ] having the
opportunity to ask questions doing all
the things they should be doing
but now because it's all theater now
they get to sit in a hearing
in front of some of this the senior
military commanders and act as if
they're a little bit surprised by all of
this and oh my god how did it happen how
could we prevent it from happening again
senator chin shaheen actually asked that
i think it was of millie saying you know
well how do we prevent this from
happening again are you [ __ ] kidding
happening again yeah that's your
question jesus christ anyway it's it's
it's i tell you what it was it was uh
yeah it's it's been
it's been a fascinating period of time
let me ask you this so the the president
has the ability to say
whatever the you know like so if if
someone advises him to leave 2 500
troops he has the ability to say i don't
think so no troops yes yes he does so he
can take all that advice
and
and the military leaders are saying look
we provided this advice right it is i i
think it does surprise people sometimes
uh when they see the extent and if they
if they were watching these these
hearings and understanding
the information flow about afghanistan
look there was a lot of talk right and
in the aftermath of this withdrawal
clown show
um
that you know what what happened who was
advising who how did we miss certain
pieces of intelligence and there's a lot
to uh to figure out there but
the idea that
that the president would sit there in
his in his office uh with all these
senior advisors around and they would
say sir here's here are your options
because that's always basically what
they're doing and theoretically they you
know they they are supposed to be strong
enough to argue
their point as strongly as possible
right they're not there to just go along
so they you know they all come in they
say we think you should be you know
keeping troops in there and the
president then steps away and now millie
mckenzie others they all said that biden
listened very you know seriously to them
but
there was a political decision here
right that political decision was
we're getting the hell out now the
interesting thing is is that biden
um
he kind of wants to have it both ways
right he wants to take credit for being
brave and saying we're getting the hell
out right
but then he also wants to blame the
previous administration for the reason
why he had to be
getting the hell out right so he wants
to blame the doha agreement that trump
signed in
february of 2020. what was that well
that was that when when the trump
administration made a deal with the
taliban
and in in uh in february of 2020 and
basically it had conditions within that
and and uh general millian mckenzie
talked about those conditions i think uh
today and they're in the hearings
actually um there were seven conditions
placed on the taliban
for this agreement to go forward and
there was a may withdrawal date
now the administration the previous
administration people don't want to hear
this [ __ ] right because they're so
entrenched in their own camp right so
people who are on the the hard left
they're not going to want to hear the
fact that the doha agreement was based
on conditions right but
the
most senior military commanders today
reaffirmed that yes there were seven
conditions for that agreement to follow
through for us to follow through we had
eight conditions for the u.s
and
now during the course of the discussions
and the negotiations and this whole
agreement was based on a power sharing
the idea was we want to create an
opportunity for the taliban and the the
afghan government we want them all to
come together and create a power sharing
agreement well
you know
on one hand you could argue and say
that's that's never going to happen
sounds crazy yeah it sounds crazy but
that's that's where they were and you
could also argue and again you know
because people are so entrenched no
one's want to give any credit to whether
they want to give credit to biden they
want to give credit to trump or any
republican president or democrat
president
you know the trump administration did
kind of broker the
hard uh
heavy lift of saying we're getting the
hell out
right
there had been talk around the edges in
previous administrations about how long
would it be there right but the drum
administration did finally actually say
[ __ ] it let's get a negotiation let's go
and let's set a time trying to get the
[ __ ] out after 20 years
right or wrong so they they put that on
the table they set the table for for
that you know hard line withdrawal
but
the taliban never met those conditions
the only thing they did was not attack
u.s troops directly
but as millie and mackenzie said today
they never met any of the other
conditions
so
it had been explained to the taliban
that
if that was the case and you don't meet
these conditions we're not going to
leave in may we're going to just keep
pushing the the withdrawal date further
to the right so why was the decision
made to withdraw then
well
look in part i think because uh i think
everybody got behind the idea that we
can't stay there forever because i think
everybody you know understood that
it just wasn't happening they weren't
buying what we were selling they never
have right i mean
and you don't want to be completely
fatalistic all the time but with
afghanistan it's not a bad it's not a
bad frame of reference to remember all
the other times that things like this
have failed
and
so the idea that somehow we were going
to build a stable
pseudo-democratic government in
afghanistan
was always flawed it was there was never
really any evidence to show that that
was going to happen
and it was propped up and i think nobody
really wanted to tell the truth
in positions of leadership whether it
was military or government or intel
community
and
so i think there was general agreement
that yeah we gotta we gotta get the [ __ ]
out
uh
and then it came down to well how do we
do that right and we faced some of the
same problems that the old soviets faced
getting the hell out of afghanistan but
i think with this case
you know part of it was
we had pulled advisors off the afghan
units you know
two three years ago right that had been
a process so the withdrawal process
had been going on for a number of years
you know over the past
decade or so you know in a sense right
we've been drawing back pulling out some
resource pulling out troops lowering the
troop numbers
putting more responsibility on
contractors
and
once you take the advisors out of the
afghan units right in a sense
you don't have really eyes and ears
right inside the afghan military so you
can have
you know president ghani or you know
some [ __ ] afghan commander just
telling you whatever you want to hear
but you didn't have a lot of folks
at ground level working with the troops
saying all right
shit's not gonna hold right particularly
after the doha agreement right once i
think that the doha agreement was made i
think the writings on the wall
and even the afghan military could see
it right and they could read it and they
could say okay
this shit's not gonna happen we're not
gonna keep getting money we're not gonna
keep getting advisors
and uh
we're not gonna get the air support that
is really the only thing that keeps us
in in power
so you know at some point
over a period of a few years we are we
were degrading our own ability to to
actually understand just how bad it was
getting right and
um
so
then it became a logistical exercise you
got to move personnel and you got to
move material
out of the country
and
that's where
you could argue
it all kind of went sideways well they
left behind how much [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] right no we
left we lost black stocks
yes yeah hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars as a conservative
estimate
uh why that's a conservative estimate
well because uh partly because you could
argue that um some of the material was
decommissioned you know some of the
heavier platforms were uh made
non-functioning okay fine um
i don't know to answer the question i
don't know why the military wouldn't
have moved more of the gear that the the
light gear out there in other words the
the night vision devices the the uh the
weaponry right the small arms uh
ammunition why not spend three or four
months right getting that gear the hell
out right you don't have the troops to
that require them right so now you've
got all this [ __ ] stored now the thought
could have been
that this is for the afghan military
they're gonna
hold but here's the here's the thing
that the interesting point that came out
from general billy and general mckenzie
during these hearings is that
they claim they're stating and i have no
reason not to believe them they're
stating that the general consensus by
the fall of 2020
right
was that without the troops in there
once you take the us troops out and the
um and and the money
then
uh the government's gonna collapse
probably by fall of this year and it
took like three hours yeah it took like
it yeah it took 11 days now in a classic
piece of washington speak i think it was
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and answering a question said no
we never saw any assessment that said
that the government would collapse in 11
days
he's very specific right he's not saying
uh in short order yeah he's just saying
11 i didn't see one for 11 days i said
we had one for like two weeks but uh so
that's that's that's just the [ __ ] that
happens on the on the side so they
assumed that the afghan army eventually
was not going to fight the taliban yes
yes so there was what they're saying is
we all and look the intel community
we've been talking about that for years
we we knew
all you had to do was study the the
soviet papers during their time their
occupation in afghanistan to understand
how we were likely going to replay that
scenario and we did right so
you know you could argue that
uh what should have happened was years
ago we should have like looked around
and thought this is a [ __ ] exercise
right doesn't mean that that
you know
and i think the military today
uh the senior commanders today and
during this week i think you'll see them
make a huge effort to say
first and foremost
the veterans uh and everyone who fought
there and and and all the the
hardship
it was and wasn't in vain i think
they're going to focus on that
and they're going to say because for two
decades
uh
the you know we haven't been attacked on
our home soil and
in a narrow definition yes that's why we
went in and then it kind of got blown up
into this idea that we were going to
create like this this bastion of
democracy in afghanistan but it's been
widely known forever that afghanistan is
insane like it's impossible to manage
yeah the soviets couldn't handle it
you know the the the whole area is
incredibly
mountainous like it's very remote it
consists of these little clans that are
run by warlords like it's not it's like
kabul is essentially the only real city
right yeah are there other cities there
there are real cities there are but
there are
it they're they're still run like little
fiefdoms and and like them was a good
word i know right
you
[Laughter]
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify